mit diesem command kann man nämlich
jeder x-beliebige blog werden
hallo ich bin hier unten
hallo ihr euch freunde das ist der neue
trend einfach ein geschirr tuch auf dem
kopf und dann dann hoch wie sonne der 2
heribert kloos in der das individuelle
macbooks ab auf der straße freunde da
läufst du ich hab richtig gehört auf der
straße freut man sich über tulpen und
man man word den den die clothes leixoes
all that you don't think jetzt ja nie
herzlich willkommen hier zu einer
weiteren folge der minecraft command ich
habe mir gedacht ich da heute am freitag
ist was ich kann mich sogar nicht mal
konzentrieren dadurch dass ich am steuer
hier vom gesichter weil heute freitag
ist kommt natürlich wieder eine folge
der minecraft command sich dieser
vorfall in minecraft zu spielen weil ich
in letzter zeit einfach viel mehr bock
auf die sich dieses ding für mich auch
einfach recht auf weiß ganz einfach so
ein bisschen verlernt wieder so ein
bisschen vielleicht liegt daran dass ich
wissen wie ihr vater hier
das riecht nach seiner mischung von pril
und persil und täler und nutella höchst
live wieder einmal sagen wir fallen
direkt aber dem ersten copa roca jetzt
bleibe hier beim thema also der erste
komplett wurde kann mich überhaupt ernst
nehmen erster command ist von joel 2579
also del 25 79
ich gebe den himmel ein und zwar befinde
ich mich gerade in der version 14 w 21 b
falls ihr euch fragten wieso hast du
keinen shader drin wie du kannst du
nicht zoomen wieso ist der ganze himmel
die ganze belichtung miteinanders das
ist ein snapshot version und zwar läuft
dieses ding nur in diesem slapshot und
wir wechseln natürlich auch gleich
wieder sie hat gleich wieder die sachen
mit shader das ist ganz klar
ich drücke erst mal drauf und zwar ist
es ein giant tree generator ihr seht
schon da oben baut sich jetzt hier
sollen so einen dingen auf und jetzt
haben wir hier gerade auch einen einen
alten bekommen das heißt revenge unten
schaut hier in der beschreibung sind die
ganze zeit nur sachen die sich da
verändern
ich weiß nicht genau wie man das aus
ausstellt ich meine das ist über ein
game room command dass man über den game
rekord auf den command block um darauf
zugreift dass der der red storm blog da
oben sich nicht die ganze aktiviert ich
könnte aber mal rein theoretisch ich
möchte jetzt endlich gesagt umgehen was
abbau nicht dass ich danach wieder alles
kaputt mache auf jeden fall zeige ich
euch jetzt einfach mal was dieses kleine
tintenfischs paul eigentlich macht und
zwar 70 es hin und wir sehen schon es
wird ein riesiger baum kreiert das ist
mega cool als wir haben hier in den baum
und auch wenn ich beispielsweise meinen
baum hier so ein bisschen an den abhang
stelle die die schon die wurzeln gehen
meistens relativ krass auch noch nach
unten also der baut sich auch nach unten
weg und es sieht wirklich so aus als ob
da solche riesen bäume stehen würde das
ganze zeit wieder bei einkommen die
halbzeit gesehen dass ich dann noch
einen command eingegeben habe also da
muss man nicht irgendwie ganz viel
eingeben sondern nur ein command man
bekommt dann quasi dieses item und dann
funktioniert also bei mir war es
wirklich sehr lange zeit so dass es
ruckelt doch gerade immer noch so ein
bisschen immer die ganze zeit aber bei
mir was die ganze zeit so am anfang dass
es gar nicht geklappt hat also ich hab
das in der 18.3 erst versucht einen
anderen version ist mir aufgefallen bei
mir funktioniert nur in der 14 23 das
haben die gar nicht gesagt in dem video
sie findet es natürlich wieder verlinkt
in der beschreibung dann kamen manchmal
auch dieses ding aber dann habe ich
keinen item bekommen dann habe ich da
mal das altern bekommen dann habe ich
auf dem boden gesetzt ist einfach nur
tintenfisch gestorben
ich weiß nicht was jetzt anders gemacht
hab jetzt eigentlich geklappt ich wollte
es unbedingt vorstellbar ist richtig
cool findet dass man so riefen bäumen
damit machen kann da kann man locker
sich ein richtig geiles baumhaus
irgendwie rein bauen und das ist
eigentlich auch schon der command nummer
eins von j l 257 9 findet alles zu einer
beschreibung und wir wechselten immer
die version zur 1.8 mit schönen kleidern
und zu anderen kommen hand so freunde
wir sind jetzt hier beim zweiten command
angelangt ihr seht schon wieder alles
ist schön mit shader und alles ist schön
aussah ich muss ja auch ein bisschen was
sehe nicht dass mich so ein bisschen
hoch das ist der swak jungs das ist das
headset wir machen direkt weiter ihr
seht schon hier luca was ist mit dir los
ich bin ein blog das habt ihr genau
richtig gesehen mit diesem command kann
man nämlich jeder x-beliebige blog
werden um zwar ist dieser command von
sap ihr findet video pace pinzette eine
beschreibung war scheiße wenn man
irgendwelche commands nimmt und es dann
nicht verlinkt das hatte ich in den
ersten folgen nicht gemacht das tut mir
leid aber jetzt findet ihr immer alle
credits unten in der beschreibung
weil die leute auch wirklich geehrt
werden müssen dafür dass ich so etwas
ausdenken
hier seht ihr schon die maschine die er
kreiert wird und ihr seht auch schon ich
habe das ganze schon gemacht weil ich
das irgendwie nicht wieder weg kriege
auch wenn ich hier es ist weg jedenfalls
habe ich hier schon ein command block
mit einem knopf dran da greife ich jetzt
einfach mal drauf zu gp den command
eines ruckelt wieder ganz kurz hat
glaube ich 24.000 zeichen oder irgendwie
so um den dreh und war mehrere stunden
an arbeit hat er im video gesagt ich
drücke einfach drauf wir bekommen hier
etwas und zwar wieder so eine maschine
gleich kommt jedoch kurzen feuerwerk
damit das ganze entfernt das sehen wir
jetzt feuerwerk entfernt und wir können
hier draufklicken get items dann
bekommen wir nämlich dieses item change
block und wir bekommen dieses item
remove block und dann erklärt sich
eigentlich alle schon von selbst und
zwar change block drobny to become the
block an die ju ich weiß nicht ob es bei
einer blume geht das heißt ich glaube
man ehre wenn ich jetzt natürlich der
der der linksblock hier und zwar nicht
einfach nur das richtige blog man auf
sätze sondern ich bin quasi einfach der
blog sowie bei haydn zieht wenn ich mich
quasi sich auf den sand stellen das item
fallenlassen bin ich dementsprechend in
sand blog hier beim wasser bin ich
natürlich nicht der wasserablauf sondern
ich bin der trailer unten drunter ist
und wenn ich dann beispielsweise auch
immer hier einfach bei den liebsten
könnte ich schon sehen ich werde darauf
das ganze funktioniert bei den ließ
nämlich auch nicht man lukas ist ja
wieder los mit meinem deutsch ihr sonst
ist es halt aber echt bei so vielen
blöcken der fall dass das ganze
funktioniert also ich könnte
beispielsweise mal hier
den stein nehmen oder hier diesen
anderen stein ich weiß noch nicht was es
ist ende seite ist das genau das
funktioniert ganze wieder hier
funktioniert wieder hier mit und was im
film schon gesehen hatte triumph blog
kann ich einfach hinschmeißen bin ich
quasi wieder weg allerdings weiß ich
nicht in eine schlucht was ich nicht
hingekriegt hat war einfach diese items
jetzt zu entfernen normalerweise kannst
du die außen inventar ziehen oder hier
auch mit gegenstände zerstören
allerdings gehen die ganzen gegenständen
beck ich glaube da müsste man dann
wieder zurück zur maschine und da
irgendwie drauf klicken
das hatte man ja auch so schon bei
einigen komme ich da ran genommen hatte
hier erst wieder am leben tun hier bei
mir hatte man ja auch schon bei manchen
fans von beispielsweise ebay minecraft
oder hipaa minecraft heißt er ja jetzt
kann ich nur die maschine hier zerstören
und die items sind immer noch da aber
wir machen einfach weiter mit command
nummer drei dann gib mir mal wieder hier
so einen schönen command block und dann
hole ich mir auch hier mal eben wieder
so ein hebel und dann füge ich dort
jetzt mal in command ein mit dem ihr
ganz ganz viel spaß haben
und zwar drücke ich jetzt mal drauf und
ihr seht schon bla bla bla bla wenn das
ding da oben den red storm blog erreicht
ist das ganze ding fertig und wir sehen
hier ist sondern sonst sondern insekten
panzerähnliches das den dicken panzer
fast luca hier so eine reihe von command
blogs aufgereiht und freunde ich möchte
ehrlich gesagt nicht hier draufklicken
weil dieser command ist von den usern
opel und zwar ist es ein virus command
was dieser command macht na ja ich drück
mal f3 ihr seht jetzt hier oben das sind
die entities gibt oder dass hier ich
glaube dass hier sind die entities da
steht gerade 133 und hier seht ihr meine
frames habe ich beispielsweise gerade 19
frames 19 frames läuft kann ich nicht so
flüssig wieder 36 als mit 30 frames auf
das müsste immer so um die 30 rum seien
aber wahrscheinlich liegt schon an der
maschine hier das team wie sie denkt die
fps diesen runter unser leser freunde
was passiert wenn ich darauf geachtet
wie gesagt auf diese auf diese zahl hier
all 142 druck drauf um ein fucking gott
15.000 23.000 30.000 45.000 48.000
60.000 ich bewege mich übrigens gerade
ich versuche gerade hoch zu fliegen
da sehe ich versuche hoch zu fliegen es
geht nichts es geht einfach gott
verdammt nichts es sind schon 121000
entities es sind die anzeige ist weg die
anzeige sekt die anzeige sex geht gar
nichts mehr ich versuchen ich dreh mich
gerade im kreis ich weiß nicht aber das
sieht was ist los vorhin was nicht so
krass alter was was passiert hier gerade
okay ich glaube wir sind klar beim
absoluten stillstand angekommen doch ein
bisschen kann ich mich noch bewegen
ein bisschen funktioniert doch ich
drücke f3 möchte er vielleicht als meine
fraps frames werde mir gerade auf 1
angezeigt 000 33 das ist cool das ist
richtig cool
ja es geht grad nichts mehr ich ich weiß
nicht ich kann ich kann nicht sagen ich
weiß nicht woran es liegt dass sage ich
einmal immer eigentlich bei
irgendwelchen sachen wo ich nicht weiß
franz liegt einfach hierbei weiß ich
woran es liegt und zwar werden extrem
viele entities quasi einfach mehr oder
weniger gespannt es sind überall in der
welt jetzt gerade command blogs mit in
welchen klassen commands ihr findet den
commander beschreibung ich will gar
nicht wissen was passiert wenn man das
ganze auf einem server anwendet freunde
dass ich will das gar nicht wissen
dieser command ist auf jeden fall den
zwei kam helfen so wie ich das hier
gerade am tun bin
ja ich weiss nicht bei mir es ist geht
hier gar nichts mehr ich kann mich mal
ab und zu mal so ein bisschen bewegen
das ist der virus komatsu weder
tatsächlich auch genannt und dem titel
beschrieben
ich kann man versuchen hier wegzufliegen
irgendwie aus dem bereich aber das geht
einfach nicht ich versuche mich gerade
aus diesem bereich zu entfernen
das wird wahrscheinlich noch ca so lange
dauern bis der dritte weltkrieg
ausgebrochen ist was wir natürlich nicht
hoffen also es wird dann unendlich lang
dauern
wenn wir zu hoffen dass er halt nie
kommt weil der zweite noch nicht mal
beendet ist sondern nur mit dem friedens
akt und was habe ich eigentlich schon
wieder wurde mir auf jeden fall
zugesendet bzw von usern zugesendet von
dem user allerdings gemacht lobte mir
findet pace pin video seinen namen
komani c3 alles in der beschreibung ich
entferne mich gerade die frames laufen
schon ich bin schon wieder bei vier
frames und damit werden quasi unendlich
viel und viele entities gespannt ich
weiß nicht ich würde ganz gerne mal f3
drücken damit sie es sehen können wie
viele das gerade sind aber funktioniert
gerade irgendwie nicht ja was soll ich
noch sagen das war es heute mit dem
minecraft commands ich hoffe euch hat
sie wieder mal gefallen wenn sie das
getan hat will ich meine bewertung voll
ist es einen klick ich hab schon ich
hatte ja leute eigentlich die so etwas
sagen schafft wir so und so viele likes
irgendwie sowas mag ich eigentlich nicht
so gerne aber ich weiß nicht schaffen
wir 10.000 dafür dass ich bei einem ding
also wenn es euch gefallen hat das
mitunter wenn nicht dann nicht wenn es
euch überhaupt nicht gefallen lassen
schreibt in die kommentare eventuell
leute die coole commands machen oder
wenn ihren cool command habt dann von
video hoch oder teilt mit dass sie mit
in den kommentaren und dann sehen wir
uns nächste woche bei dem video days in
berlin
oder wir sehen uns jemand anders wieder
und vergesse ich den zweck einer das ist
es ist los gegangen
das ding jetzt gab es viele fragen ich
mal meine haare aussehen wenn ich kein
geld und habe die sind einfach so die
sind so die sehen so aus wie die haare
so ein bisschen so wie üblich und dann
so zur seite darüber finde ich
allerdings jetzt nicht so cool wie ich
hasse dich und deswegen habe ich dann
mir gedacht ich dreh den swag so ein
bisschen auf meinem tollen bendiner hier